how'd you become a boss though because
that's where the controversy comes in
much moisture controversy so you're in
jail you're in prison with Joey you guys
are thinking about coming out there's a
strategy to create a war because it's an
opportunity for you to take over you
might enjoy and then you know you know
it's very very very very very simple
yeah I became a bush cause I said I'm
the boss
I can move anybody that doesn't like it
I don't hide I Drive around the country
track
you could come I was always and I was on
the parole and I had a pistol on me
cause I'm come you know how many people
send up nobody squeeze me for raising my
voice is just I remember what my dad had
to do so you came out of normal swore
you when you became a boss there was no
I was sworn in already but I even forgot
to tell when the only swimming is that I
ever had was me Angelo Bruno and caller
gave me the book all three of us cut off
fingers call us so that's gotta be a
person we want it that way you belong to
me and you belong Vinge now that's why
they sent me to Chicago nobody could
touch me that's why and you want to
listen to people you I don't know what
you're doing but kind of enjoy so you
decide I've never met George you he's a
punk he's a liar and he's afraid of
people I saved his life they wonder kill
him from New York I said I'll put my
life up for him let ask him then what
he's done to people the money goes to
people his mother he resisted why even
talk about it
you guys both got out in 2011 all right
did you stay at the same place or know
where you and Joey should work change
placing prison know who was at a
different place in you he could stay
with me I
as those are boys I'll beat the [ __ ] out
of them that punk you don't know how to
fight that's what he is
I'm telling you what they are they cheat
on their but they did everything you
hurt everybody
he owes everybody now he's walking the
street the boss he made himself the boys
he's a boy
nobody nobody looks at him he can't get
nobody
Himalayan Lilly we're like this when
they were friends they couldn't come
near Salva Jasmine they couldn't come
near him true man a true man
you
[Music]